Ewan McGregor has gone on the record several
times over the years to say he would be delighted
to reprise his role as Obi-Wan Kenobi if anything
came up, but that he didn't know of anything
on the horizon.
As late as 2017, he was quoted as saying he
hadn't met with anyone in any way about a
formal return.
Turns out that was a big fat lie.
McGregor successfully bamboozled the public
for a long time, as he's known of a planned
Obi-Wan Kenobi standalone for four years.
He revealed this little fact during an interview
with Men's Journal just before going on-stage
at D23 to make the big announcement of the
Obi-Wan series.
According to him:
"For four years, I've been having to lie to
people about it."
Perhaps this shouldn't come as such a shock,
though, as it's been reported for a couple
of years that Lucasfilm was attempting to
put together a project about Obi-Wan.
Technically, the official reports from legitimate
sources about the project have never said
Lucasfilm was in talks with McGregor, though
rumors have been swirling for months.
Of course, he'd at least be aware the project
existed after it got as far as picking up
a director in Extremely Loud & Incredibly
Close filmmaker Stephen Daldry.
Until now, it would have been far too much
of a commitment on Lucasfilm's part to announce
any ties between McGregor and a project like
this.
Even if McGregor was only providing advice
to a new Obi-Wan actor, fans would have flipped
their lids even just knowing that he was working
with Lucasfilm at all.
For McGregor to actually star in an Obi-Wan
Kenobi project?
That would have made the Star Wars-loving,
rumor-creating, opinionated public wild, so
it was wise of the studio to keep things quiet
until all the plans were locked in place.
McGregor's secrecy goes deeper than that,
however.
When talking to Coming Soon about the Obi-Wan
Kenobi series' production cycle, McGregor
revealed that the project was originally pitched
as a single film.
He shared:
"It wasn't always going to be a series, not
initially.
When we first started talking about, that
wasn't really in the cards but everything's
changed so much, so quickly.
It's really exciting that it is now.
I'm really into the idea to be able to tell
the story over several hours instead of just
one hit.
I think it's going to be quite cool."
That admission implies that McGregor has been
very aware of the project since well before
Daldry was attached as director.
Daldry has since exited the project, with
The Mandalorian's Deborah Chow now directing
the Disney+ Obi-Wan series.
Can you imagine a better comeback story?
McGregor, a longtime Star Wars fan, got the
job of a lifetime in the late 1990s when he
was cast as the younger Obi-Wan Kenobi in
Star Wars: The Phantom Menace.
Sadly, the legacy of the Star Wars prequel
films has been lackluster at best.
But more than a few fans would argue that
McGregor's role was a rare gem that somewhat
redeemed the trilogy.
For him to come back to his career-defining
role now in a solo production where he can
call the shots as an executive producer must
be a joy.
From what we understand now, it's clear that
Lucasfilm, Disney, and specifically Kathleen
Kennedy want McGregor's creative thoughts
on display for nostalgia's sake.
It's encouraging right out of the gate to
know that the series will have creative input
from the man playing the character.
As of this writing, there's no confirmed information
on plot, timeline, or additional characters
to be featured on the Obi-Wan Kenobi series,
but that almost doesn't matter right now.
McGregor is on the cusp of a fandom homecoming,
and Star Wars fans everywhere can take a ton
of solace from the answer to one question
alone:
"Ewan, are you going to be playing Obi-Wan
Kenobi again?"
"Yes."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.